hello everyone welcome back to big mood
wow
i'm in a [ __ ] mood right now i'm just
kidding i don't know why it's like we
have a guest we have again tighten up
[Music]
uh we have a very special guest one of
our favorite returning guests mrs stacy
diaz hi
everyone thank you for having me we
haven't seen your face in a while so
we're really yeah i literally feel like
i did i saw you guys not that long ago
no it's been a while yeah we haven't
seen you in 2021 i don't think no way i
did really like in tony twentynine i
think we did a tree girl video yeah
like listen i have no memory the other
way where i'm like i haven't seen you in
years
he's like you could have said i saw you
last month and i believe yeah i i feel
like i mean i do miss you guys i'm happy
to be back yes thank you for having me
we also have miss gina darling miss new
boobies
you know i'm a little bit jesus that i
can't really see them and we had to go
through all of this of you being gone
pixar didn't happen honestly you guys
are still healing a little bit still
sore man my nipples are sore as hell
mike's cute and i didn't even get my
boobs done oh
i feel like this is this is what it
feels like when you have to breastfeed
and women always say it [ __ ] hurts
like [ __ ] none of us wouldn't know it
yeah
she's giving a a a very neutral face we
don't know we can't read her we'll never
find out my nipples are so sore i can't
even put a blanket over them sometimes
oh my god
one time i boogie boarded too long and i
couldn't put shirts because those are so
cheap oh my god
you only have to learn that lesson once
they all
okay well today the episode that we
wanted to do is an unpopular opinions
because you know we like to all give our
opinions on everything and we have like
pretty diverse perspectives we do
we do and stacy is great at giving her
opinion on things she has an opinion on
a lot of things which first of all is
good for entertainment because she
actually has an opinion and she has good
opinions too and a lot of insights there
was this one episode you were on that i
didn't get to be on with you but i was
like you had an unpopular opinion and i
was agreeing with you from behind the
camera
and i just wanted to know right now
which one was that we'll save it yeah
i'll give it to you when we're in the
thick of it okay i'd also like to say
that all of our opinions are correct no
matter what anyone says yes yeah even if
they're different if you follow my
instagram story like half of my memes
are like oh i was right and i knew it
all right
you always know i'm right me watching
you google me to know that i'm right
so um do you should do you guys have any
of your own because we we took some
audience submissions so i do have an
audience first and then
wait wait can i start off yeah
give us a good one no because you guys i
have been thinking about this and i was
like should i make a tick tock about it
should i make a whole video but i really
was like this is a perfect moment okay
so yeah
all of you know because you've seen me
but maybe your audience is saying i'm
tall i'm 5 10. yes
i
hate
and it's like i love all of you but when
people tell me oh my god you're so tall
what do i do with that information
you're like oh [ __ ]
what did anyone tell me what and so my
unpopular opinion is what is the point
of telling somebody that
um i think it's like uh
i think it's when people just don't know
what to say like when they're like
surprised
i know they shouldn't say anything
because do you feel different if people
are like oh my god you're so pretty
no that's that's right so
do you feel like why do you feel like
you take that differently than oh my god
you're so pretty why do you take it
differently i think because you're so
tall people don't really mean it like
you're so pretty you're so tall it's
like a shock value like oh and you're so
pretty as like admiration
or do you think it's because like pretty
stuff can be adjusted because how you do
your makeup and your hair and stuff and
your tall is not something that's like
going up to me saying wow you're so
asian and it's like yeah nobody says
that about anything else i've never gone
up to someone and being like oh my god
you're so fat right oh my god your hair
so dark why do you point that out yeah
steve can relate to you because he's
pretty tall and people say that all the
time he's 6'4
and he's like [ __ ] yeah i am but yeah
that is for a guy i guess maybe they
love hearing that but maybe i think
because you're it's just annoying no
okay not about anyone specifically yeah
but it's just like what is the point of
telling a tall person yeah they already
know what am i supposed to do
thank you
what do i say yeah i'm always like yes i
am yeah
i know yeah i guess i get that well for
me i don't see
oh my god you're so tall as a bad thing
because i actually really love when
women are super yeah it's not a bad
thing it's just awkward it's just like a
strange thing to say yeah if i came up
to you and i was like oh my god you're
so white yeah we say that to her all the
time
people
it's constant jokes about how pale i am
so yeah yeah it's just she's our she's
our token white person so what happens
to a guy and you're like oh my god
you're so short right what would he do
he would be pissed
this is going to sound like a backwards
compliment or like a it sounds like i'm
bragging a humble brag okay but okay it
used to bug me and i swear it did really
bug me i'm not just bringing this up but
when people would be like your eyelashes
are so long what mascara do you use okay
i know it sounds like a helmet
but they legit wanted me to give them my
mascara brand that i use and i wanted to
be like girl it's just like it just is
it just is it's not going to matter what
mascara i tell you
unpopular opinion um actually very
popular opinion no one wants to hear you
brag about your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna say
and i've said this for years bohemian
rhapsody is a terrible song [ __ ] you
[ __ ] no way you can't get out get out
this is my house
what did i say before it was correct why
is it a terrible song because it's like
someone made a song and couldn't decide
what it wanted to be four times in the
middle that's what's great about it yeah
no no no no and he's just like no it
makes it great because i'm displaying
all of my skills it's like no you just
couldn't pick one song
and then whoever chooses bohemian
rhapsody during karaoke is so [ __ ]
selfish everyone likes it it's like 30
hours we all join in we love joining in
like pick a genre and like pick a song
what's your karaoke song what's your
karaoke song barbie girl it's really
it's a fun song you get to make funny
voices
barbie
you know no one [ __ ] wants to hear
barbie girl everyone loves that you're
the annoying drunk [ __ ] that everyone's
like oh
we're the fun crowd that gets bohemian
rhapsody it's like i remember the first
time i heard it i was like oh this is a
oh there's another oh and it's changing
again when is this over like we wait for
those parts we're like here comes this
part
it's a it's like a movie
in a song if i wanted a movie i'd go
watch a movie it's a classic it is i
know it's like you can't change classics
how dare you i mean you know what just
get the [ __ ] out of us
you want to do the rest of this episode
now because i want you to get the kids
nailing this right now
that's all real good
no thank you don't ever say that in a
room with any white person ever again
that's true they're called churches yeah
that is my culture and i'm very offended
why people love that [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] say [ __ ] about journey if
you say [ __ ] about you like journey they
got a filipino singer now okay so
i do like journey oh my god okay we need
to move on because i'm heated oh my gosh
i'm waiting for the jess rage to come
out i'm so excited this is an audience
submission here we're going to keep
everyone anonymous
because we don't know if they want us to
share who they are or not but this one
just says and i haven't really gone
through these tiff picked these and shot
them over to me so
um this one says i hope you guys see
this oh my god because i don't see this
top topic talked about that much so
she's very excited
um marriage isn't necessarily for a long
lasting strong relationship
that was in quotes marriage isn't
necessarily is it sorry marriage isn't
necessary for a long-lasting strong
relationship
truly if you want those tax breaks and
you're going to be long-term anyway like
why not yeah and then like if like
someone dies or whatever i want to be
taken care of i feel like that's not
that unpopular people in the united
states are married a lot of people don't
get married well i mean obviously
marriage is still a very contentious
subject she's just saying i just don't
see not yet at least how a contract
strengthens your relationship other than
legal and financial stuff but i think
i'd love my partner the same
or even more true
you will love them more but if you're
already all the way in why not just get
married yeah i i will say we were me and
steve were like so like dead we're good
to be gonna be together forever right
before we got married yeah and when we
got married it i didn't think it could
get better it got way better i felt like
we started actually operating like
a unit like uh like before we were like
supportive of each other and
complimentary but like add something for
some reason some subconscious thing like
we really started acting as like a unit
after that and it's the highest level of
commitment yeah to me it's like yeah
we're going to be together forever but
you don't want to get married why mm-hmm
yeah i would want to know more why
someone doesn't want to get married like
i guess it's what does it come what
comes up for you if you don't want to
get married yeah like what's the issue
like but i there's times where i could
see where marriage could [ __ ] people
over obviously financially that's the
biggest thing but if you take that out
of it not assuming everyone's a [ __ ]
up person i guess that's what it's
saying is like i trust you not to [ __ ]
me over yeah for sure that's a whole
relationship
even having a relationship with someone
is saying here's my heart please be
careful and now it's like here's all my
finances too please [ __ ] be careful
what do you think that is just scary oh
my god do you think you can reach the
pinnacle of your relationship without
taking that step like do you think you
could really fully have the fullest
there's life relationships i think
that's um that's all personal preference
for me like steve and i have both been
like pretty traditional people so we
always wanted to get married like since
we were little and our parents are both
married and have stayed married so i
think we weren't
you know a lot of kids that came from
divorced families like maybe don't
necessarily see marriage as a stable
thing but we both came from like stable
marriages so we were always like we want
to get married to that person so yeah
it's it's all definitely personal
preference but what's that like oh
yeah yeah you're like no one was weird i
have long eyelashes and i came from a
stable marriage
i'm probably
and i've been in therapy for years
because of it i've still been in therapy
for years um but i mean yeah marriage is
great and i feel like even you saying
like oh you know it is very unstable
when you do come from a broken family
you have to fight and kind of
rewire your brain to think this is
something that could possibly be good
and it's not going to fall apart just
because in my parents it did yeah you
know so it like
there was a point where i even
questioned why do i want to get married
it's a lot more complicated there are
finances like it's weird but then when
you're fully in love like i am now you
should just like you know what [ __ ] it
like whatever the money is whatever the
finances are it's the biggest contract
or one of the biggest contracts we're
all gonna sign in our lives
but when you love the person you're just
like
it is what it is i love him so much and
if it's important to one person then you
compromise to make it important for both
because that's what relationships are
and you get a prenup
hot topic
that's a hot topic right that is
unpopular um
popular opinion i think it depends on
the relationship um
i don't know gina would you get a
premium
if i'm taking myself off the market and
i'm gonna have your kids i'm gonna
destroy my body and take care of this
[ __ ] kid and all that [ __ ] i'm not
signing no [ __ ] prenup i'm taking
the money yeah you're what if i have you
you've got some money girl what if you
marry a guy
i just need a hitman
hello problems give some life insurance
yeah no but like let's say you're the
one with the money and like you just
marry a dude that i mean
everybody's normal but you married a
dude who has a nine to five and he's not
super successful he's successful but you
know the he makes a lesson there's a
disparity
i feel is like 55k i think so i think my
prenup would be like yo like
it will be written like if someone
cheats yeah they don't get [ __ ] yeah
yeah like
because your printo can be very very
detailed yeah so it's gonna be very
detailed whatever drawn out yeah i'm not
just gonna sign one with my husband be
like if we get divorced you get fifty
percent of half or anything for like no
reason at all mine's gonna be very very
cute there's a lot of states too where
like even if you have a very detailed
prenup after like a certain number of
years you've been married it kind of
goes null anyway and you have to do a
post up and like re-sign the contract
again so like there's like a
presentation expire in certain states i
believe so why um i would definitely
sign a premium my opinion on this is if
when you got together there was a huge
income disparity yeah like a huge asset
disparity um and you're truly in love
and getting married for the right
reasons then a prenup shouldn't matter
like sign the parent because who cares
you're not planning on getting divorced
for sure but if you guys are both at the
same income level like
why go through the extra step like if
you're gonna like get money from your
parents when they pass or if you're
gonna get houses passed down to you that
had nothing to do with them with them
then yeah sure sign the prenup but i
feel like we're both pretty even like my
partner and i so i'm like yeah well
let's build together it's not like i
have a house like i have my businesses
but thankfully those are registered
under their own you know so if he could
still
he could but i mean at that point yeah
oh stressful i think everyone should get
one just because it's better to
stay now when you're in love and
everything's fine what you would want to
happen when it ends because people
do change when they're pissed off
is when one person's like hella in debt
and then you inherit their debt
and also when you're married and someone
like we see in this uh i don't know if
anyone follows a real housewives of
beverly hills but so this lawyer
uh was like stealing money from his
clients i guess now his wife is getting
thrown into it like was she involved
like because they're married so it's
like she's kind of taking on his like
criminal [ __ ] charges maybe you know
so okay if you put it that way okay
maybe i will i feel like being married
is risky so there should there just
should be a lot of like there's
shouldn't be any reason why you can't
put things on paper regardless yeah i
will say though like
if there is a prenup i get to keep all
my shoes because i have rothies yeah and
i don't want them to take my rothies uh
it's 20 21 and nobody has time for
uncomfortable shoes and that's where
rothy's come in uh their styles are
sustainably made with materials like
plastic water bottles it's fully machine
washable and available in tons of shapes
styles and colors so you can always find
the right one for you they're so
comfortable yeah i got the uh the red
pointy ones
i got the tennis shoes my little pop of
color start somewhere off on the right
foot with comfortable bestseller flats
loafers and sneakers from rothys with
sandals in an array of colors to shoes
why can't i read today do they surgery
your eyes weird right
yeah
oh my god with sandals in an array of
colors to shoes made for exploring their
newest styles have you covered plus
their spacious washable bags are perfect
for summer getaways rothy's also
recently launched a men's line that are
durable washable and created with nearly
zero waste oh you know men need some
washable shoes yeah that's true
step up your summer wardrobe with
washable sustainable stylish shoes and
bags from rothys head to rothys.com big
mood to find your new favorites today
again that's r o t h y s
dot com slash big mood and if we were to
get a prenup i would want the mattress
because it's so comfortable oh my
goodness uh purple is our sponsor today
for mattresses and uh so freaking
comfortable they got the like what is
that the egg thing the purple grid the
grit yeah the grid it's a stretchy gel
material that's amazingly supportive for
your back and legs i got back issues so
it's hella comfortable for that and
scoliosis yeah yeah i have scoliosis and
it's like this kind that goes like this
and i have like tension there it's a
whole deal i'm old anyway um
hot wheels race trash back there
because of how it's designed too the
grid doesn't trap air air actually
circulates and flows through it so
you'll never overheat if you're one of
those sweaty sleepers like my husband
the grid bounces back as you move and
shift unlike memory foam which remembers
everything remembers too much that's why
memory foam has craters and divots and
right now you can try your purple
mattress risk free with free shipping
and returns financing is also available
so purple really is for comfort for an
uncomfortable world right now you'll get
10 off any order of 200 or more go to
purple.com big mood 10 and use promo
code bigmood10 that's
purple.com10 promo code big mood 10 for
10 off any order of 200 or more
purple.com big move 10 promo code big
mood 10 term supply all right give me an
unpopular opinion okay you want another
one yeah hit me i want i want to see
oh agreed the people on the east coast
have no [ __ ] taste buds that [ __ ] is
trash what is it
i hit the mic that sauce that it comes
with
yeah raising raisin canes is just a fast
food chain for um chicken strips is it
from the east coast it is so good their
bread is so good it's just thick bread
it's big bread that's all it is
toasted
it's delicious maybe i haven't gone to
the right location they all taste the
same they're good it gives me a
stomachache basically you're talking
about dry convention center chicken
strips
with that boring ass sauce that
everyone's into pouring sauce and just
boring sauce
no thanks
big boy bread big boy bread texas toast
is what they call them
really oh that's thick oh that's what
i'm saying it's no thick bread it's so
good no
i can't
i'm gonna have to try it again because
i've only had it like four years ago and
i was like i'm never coming back but
maybe i should try it again because
people like it i don't get it i love it
nikki both
she's like fake vomiting over here
um i'm trying to find one that would
piss me off but i haven't getting heated
reading through them just give us one
give us one for we're going to give us
give this one right now unless raising
canes wants to sponsor us in that case
it's funny oh yeah you delicious i don't
think they were celebrating
podcast sponsorships i had an opinion
before the shoot started but that jess
wanted me to say on camera but she
didn't even know what it was and i don't
know if she wants me to say it but
i don't know if it's unpopular it's just
an opinion that i realized that everyone
on the show is either a water sign or a
fire sign
and every guest that has been really
liked on the show has been a water sign
or a fire sign hello prove me wrong i
haven't had that many guests well that
is high they've all been water signs or
fire signs i'm a fire sign you guys yeah
same stinky blind proven
double fire you guys who else do we have
a cat fire sign oh she's leo no wait
maybe she's cancer no she's not cancer
wait wait wait she thinks she's a leo
fourth of july oh wait oh
foreign okay water sign
[Laughter]
okay well that was my unpopular opinion
was that was stupid but yeah thank you
crazy crystal
thank you
i'm just kidding i'm kidding stacy's
here she likes that [ __ ] so she loves it
too i know i do we looked up jessa's
[ __ ] and like stacey was like damn she's
all kind of emotion
she's all cancer and then what was your
gemini racing you guys i'm a gemini
raising i know we're out here
surviving i'm out here surviving
it's hard out here out here surviving i
mean
yeah
gemini rice is your partner an earth
sign no he's a water sign oh okay oh
[ __ ] i love cancers oh so sexist right
you guys get in heated arguments we
hardly ever get in heated arguments yeah
i think he lets you win no i think it's
because i've been through so much
therapy i don't know i'm just like
i'm an evolved aries you know i'm pretty
self-aware of final form
no no i'm not in phoenix yet you know
but i just i choose my fights
all the aries men i've known have been
absolutely trashed yeah
mary's women have seen so far been on
that same with leo guys haven't gone
along with them but leo women super get
along with that thanks yeah fire sign
women it seems like men are the problem
i'm in
anyway we're gonna move on um okay so
this girl says that college is only
worth it if you know your specific
career path i think a great waste of
money if it's like i don't necessarily
need i could get behind this yeah i saw
someone sent me a dm directly she she
didn't read the assignment and sent me
directly so somebody shouldn't go to
college
no so but this other one was a teacher
actually specifically like a i think
middle school or elementary school
teacher or something but she was just
saying like i hate that we have to push
all of our students directly into the
college path because she knows that like
not everyone needs the college degree we
actually still need a lot of technical
skill
type of people or sometimes people
realize what they want to do later and
they already chose the wrong major like
after they graduated they're like oh
actually i wanted to study this but they
spent all this money on yeah studying
the wrong thing i feel like they kind of
bamboozled us into believing that it was
like a path directly to success
and i didn't finish college but there
are so many people who are in so much
debt like there was a point so i went to
pasadena city college when i transferred
to cal state la
um i stopped playing volleyball so when
i was playing volleyball it was really
fun because i was basically going to
school to play yeah and then when that
motivating factor was taken out when i
just transferred to go to school i was
like this is boring i hate school like
it's not fun it's not something i enjoy
doing and i don't think it's supposed to
be fun though but i mean it's supposed
to at least
like there are people who enjoy it or
fulfill something yeah like they feel
very fulfilled by it and there was a
point i remember when i was in class and
i spent the two hour class on instagram
and the teacher was just like
like blankly staring at nothing
obviously not very passionate about his
job and i was like what am i doing here
like i'm leaving i'm never coming back
we had a bad experience i think well
here's my theory is like if you look at
college what it's supposed to be is an
investment in your career right it's
supposed to train you at a higher level
to then you go in your career and you
make all that money back
it pays for itself but college has
gotten so inflated in the tuition prices
where the job market is so deflated
there's like no jobs like guaranteed job
security anywhere so you're not
guaranteed to make your investment back
at all in fact it's really slim chance
that you make there's no guarantees in
any investment right that's true so i'd
rather invest in the thing that like if
unless you die hard on the career path
you want don't invest anything yet yeah
and wait until you know what you want to
invest in that's a good point you could
wait like not everyone necessarily has
to go to college right at uh graduating
high school and it's like they're
expecting these kids to choose your life
path right after high school like you
just lost
like two months ago you know we're
trying to figure out how you just had
prom you still look like you and then i
remember when i was 17 years old um and
i was kind of lost
i was about to graduate so i posted on
my on my
facebook and i had a lot of older peers
i was like hey
i have a question to ask you guys did
you go to college uh are you using your
degree now and was it worth it for you
and literally i think like 9 out of 10
answers was i went to college i my
my degree is just collecting dust and my
career now has nothing to do with my
degree and i was like this is a waste of
money and they're still in debt i know
attorneys
that i'm making more money than because
they're still in debt from school same
yeah like i know but attorneys are most
likely to make a [ __ ] million dollars
a year later on down the road so i don't
feel bad down the road so it's just more
like if you're gonna go to college it
has to be for a very specific like you
definitely need college to be an
attorney all the stem stuff is very very
necessary like so let's say so my
sister-in-law is a veterinarian yeah so
she needed to go through a lot of
schooling like all the medical schooling
to become a veterinarian so the more
schooling the more debt right and she
still hasn't paid off her student loans
and she's like has a family a house now
like they're basically paying two almost
two almost three mortgages to pay for
both of their students because her her
husband is a professor and so he had to
get a phd
and uh yeah so they're like spending so
much money just on repaying that debt
and they yeah they make a six-figure
income but their take-home pay is like
30 grand a year because after taxes and
paying off student loan debt it's just
is it a good investment no and you know
what makes me piss it makes me upset
because as
in the latino community our parents are
immigrants and we're literally told go
to college go to college go to college
because then you're going to have
something guaranteed yeah and a lot of
times we're pushed to go to college and
we get these degrees in business
communications um like useless degrees
i'm sure there's people out there doing
great with them but the vast majority of
people are not using their degree for
that and they think that by having this
paper it's going to be like walking into
a place and being like look at my degree
can i get hired and you don't because it
used to be it's me i know but it upsets
me because i'm like you're literally
getting into so much debt
and you're letting these 18 year olds
get like thousands of dollars me as a 30
year old it would be so hard to get
like an 80 000 loan for anything but
they give it to an 18 year old for
school
because they know that they lock you in
yeah and then there's people who
literally have been paying for years and
they still haven't even made a dent
and their
um what is it called and they're dead
because you know what public schooling
doesn't teach finances actual finances
so people don't even know because that's
just the path that's been carved for
them already yeah i think that's what
they're supposed to do but same came
from immigrant families and um back in
the 80s maybe that was true like you get
a degree it also didn't cost as much to
go to school you get your degree and
then you did have some some job security
out there to use your degree with it's
not the case now you're still living off
antiquated uh lifestyles and that's just
not
it's not how the world works right now i
know and it's so sad because then you
see like 18 year olds 19 year olds now
and you're like man i don't even know
what to tell you like i don't know what
to tell you to do because college was a
great experience for those classes where
there was critical thinking and you got
to have so many different opinions and i
learned a lot about myself by going to
college for the time that i did
but one of the best decisions i made for
myself and my career looking back now
was walk out of that school when i did
you know there's no way i could have
known that i was going to be here back
then but in my heart i just felt like
this is not the place where i need to be
yeah and i wish there was someone would
be able to kind of figure that out i
guess if they think about yeah i think
kids are kids are better now because
they've taken all the lessons from our
generation the gen x or whatever like
the generation just above us and us the
millennial generation so i think gen z
is is more aware more aware of a lot of
stuff and then so by the generation
after them i think they're going to be
even further aware i will say though
that we live in an information age so
even if you do drop out of college i am
super huge on continued education like
lifelong education like you should
always be learning learning learning and
especially when you do find the thing
that you want to do like go hard on it
get coaching get uh get into a
conservatory program go into a technical
school or whatever it is like to really
hone in on like what your passion is i
will say though i mean i have a master's
degree and i don't regret it so for
certain people obviously college is
still the direction that they need to go
in and the degree is still the only
reason why i'm going to get the job that
i can get is because i have that degree
yeah so i mean if you have a certain
path like obviously engineers they need
it doctors anything in stem anything
math science anything related like
that's there's still value in that so i
feel like that's maybe a little bit of
an unpopular opinion is like yeah some
people do actually still value college
true it's very popular to say oh don't
go to college you don't need it oh you
think that's popular yeah i really feel
like that was a lot of background in the
culture in the culture now
no
online everyone's always like oh don't
go to college you don't need it i don't
know i'm not a mexican house i hear that
a lot
i think maybe in la it could be
considered everyone wants to be like
in social media now so they're like oh i
don't [ __ ] go to college every time
i've said hey make sure you really know
what you want before you like really
invest in college i've gotten so much
hate for it on i've mentioned it on jks
a certain amount of times people think
i'm bitter because i dropped out i had a
full ride scholarship and i dropped out
like i didn't need i didn't need to get
into student loan debt and i still
dropped out because it just wasn't the
right thing yeah but it's not the right
thing for everyone but i still get a lot
of backlash and i'm not saying don't go
to college i'm not batching bashing
college at all i'm just saying like you
really need to know that you what you're
studying and that you want it needs to
be intentional in that field yeah but we
need to not make technical jobs seem
less yeah because like you create
six figures in a trade job like so
that's it you don't have not everything
has to be white collar work
to be yeah worth it and i think
everybody's different you know like
school was hard for me like
studying sitting in a place and studying
for hours
never did that like literally i was
getting degrees all the way through i
was going to school to play volleyball
yeah i was like i [ __ ] love
volleyball and if i need to get seats to
play i'm going to do it yeah and then as
soon as that was taken out i was like oh
[ __ ] i actually don't want to be here
you know so it's about realizing what
works for you and what you want to do so
i admire people who have degrees because
that shows that you have delayed
gratification like you can follow
through yeah follow through but we need
that you know we need people who go into
the county we need people who become
plumbers we need people
who do everything we need psychologists
we need people who go through these
things it's just a it's a risk no matter
what yeah so the risk that i took was
like i dropped out to pursue acting
full-time and it was like that was a
huge risk because obviously that's such
a hard industry to make it in and i
didn't necessarily make it in acting but
i but i went full force on it i went to
a conservatory program and like paid for
i was working three jobs to pay for it
because my parents wouldn't support me
because i dropped out of college so i
was paying rent and i was like i was
really trying to make that dream work
and it was a huge risk and so is college
but college isn't treated as the risk
that it is and i think that's the
difference yeah is that people see
college as a guaranteed job and it's
really not and i don't think they do
anymore though they do like who's they
though because parents everything
all of the millennial generation and all
of the generation below us none of them
see colleges and guarantee things and we
all lived through the 2008 crisis a lot
of people in our generation got a degree
right through 2008 financial crisis and
all of them [ __ ] didn't get jobs
although the like young parents i know
that have their kids they still have
college funds set up for them they still
want them to go to college but maybe not
get into
but a lot of them too have college funds
set up but they'll also allow their kids
to use that for other things too i think
like school they need to push trade
schools more trade schools definitely
need to be pushed way more absolutely
more yeah because i always i remember
like growing up thinking like oh why
would you go to a trade school like it
always didn't sound because
who wants to do that blue collar work
and be a plumber be a electrician
whatever and then i when i grew up i was
like dude that's like good money yeah
and there's some of the happiest people
i know exactly also can you imagine not
having um construct like contractors and
stuff that are good at their work in
america like we need good infrastructure
it's really hard to get an electrician
to come over here because they're big
ones yeah it's hard to get good
contractors for a lot of people like us
like we don't like schooling we don't
like studying in like papers and [ __ ]
like my little brother hates school
can't focus doesn't like it at all but
fixing cars he loves it so he wants to
go to school for that
people that are good at mechanics yeah i
like that too i think once you find your
passion just go hard on it like study it
as much as you can get better at it keep
improving like
master that craft i think it's easier to
say that because we're like older but at
19 you would have told me scary and i
would have been like what the [ __ ] is my
volleyball's my passion at that point
you know yeah and i took it as far as i
could yeah so i mean just take the time
to find yourself yeah and go to therapy
yeah definitely that's that's one thing
for sure i think our generation learned
going to therapy yeah well this one is a
little bit connected so i guess we could
just take a couple more minutes or a
minute um this person said working a
nine-to-five job is not overrated i
enjoy structure having weekends off
knowing at 5 pm when i clock out i don't
need to think about work yeah i know
they still like that yeah so that's
where i was getting out with the like oh
it's not cool to go to college and have
a nine to five anymore like that's
definitely very much of a loud thing
that i hear a lot as someone who did go
all the way through to get a master's
program and is going back into a nine to
five it does feel like now i'm counter
culture really because i think it was
always like if you think back when we
were teenagers it was still cool to be
like i'm going to be an nba star i'm
going to be a rapper i'm going to be a
like an actor like it was still cool to
not take the traditional route like
that's what you're vocalizing but the
majority of people still did take the
traditional the only difference is that
now
being a vlogger is so attainable
everybody has access to a camera into
youtube the difference with being an nba
player is that you had to work your ass
off yeah those people are so talented
and like their work ethic is insane
yeah top one percent anybody can be
actual talent
but you but they don't know how hard it
is to be consistent on youtube like yeah
it's hard you have a youtube channel and
sit down
you gotta edit like they think that just
the oh like are you talking a camera and
then you just be at home all day and
it's like no like there's you got to
edit you got to be consistent you got to
set a schedule you have to be your own
boss which is oftentimes harder than
plucking into work and like you just do
your job and then clock out like you
have to set your own schedule and stick
to it yeah i always get um
like comments from bitter old people
like oh all you do is just sit in the
camera and be pretty it's like dude for
all these years we have to do everything
ourselves our own marketing our own ads
and it takes a lot of work to be pretty
okay it does okay to get new boobs every
couple years yeah can you say this to
your point i left the nine to five world
because i was like nah [ __ ] that we're
getting crazy up here
did this for six years and now i'm like
nah [ __ ] that that [ __ ] is way too much
some people do need structures yeah
right no structure i do people who can't
like just be like i don't know what i'm
doing today but for me and now that i am
in a nine to five i'm just like what the
[ __ ] is this
where do you guys find time like i have
to take my cat to the vet when do i do
that
on weekends like i'm trying to go to the
bathroom yeah i'm trying to figure this
[ __ ] out hire people to do [ __ ] for you
because they're working all day it's
like it's a it's a huge shift like for
me i went like i've always been the free
spirit i sleep at [ __ ] five in the
afternoon if i want to and then the
shift to nine to five is just so bizarre
for me i mean i can do it yeah but it's
strange and it's just it depends on what
people like it's it's um some people
crave structures and others don't like i
talk to my friends and they're like you
know i'm so envious of you you can go on
vacations whenever you want you can do
like sleep in as much as you want i'm
like yeah that's cool but grass is also
greener your job security is there the
grass the grass is not greener taking a
vacation is a risk here yeah
i can do it but yeah like you're not
going to get like i can i can [ __ ] up
somewhere and my career is gone yeah
you're
like you you know your job's there
yeah that's why i'm like i can't see
myself trying to compete
with these young kids now like social
media is a young person's game me trying
to think about competing with these kids
into my 40s and my 50s i'm like i can't
oh i don't think i was competing like i
i'm like oh i like the niche that i'm in
and i like i really don't even care to
be relevant because then you're like the
kid you're thinking of kids that are
like huge it's like yeah well they
appeal to a general audience of
teenagers like i'm appealing to
this group of people that's into these
things and that's all i care about like
i i like making content for them and i i
resonate with it and it's like a back
and forth and i really like the
community yeah um and as long as that
stays or it starts to evolve and i'm
never like
getting
bored or stressed out about it then i'm
i'm pretty happy with the ups and downs
there i will say though having so many
people's opinions of you yeah constantly
is really hard for your mental health
that is so hard that's probably the
hardest thing
about social media and maybe it's an
unpopular opinion because since a lot of
people haven't experienced it you know
because in your real life people talk
[ __ ] about you behind your back and
maybe you hear about it maybe you don't
most of the time you don't hear about it
and you're just like oh sally's a [ __ ]
because you know she's a two-faced [ __ ]
here you're constantly reading what
people think about you what you do wrong
what you do right it is also when they
have limited information so a lot of
it's wrong too and you want to be like
no that's not wrong correctly correct
them but then yeah it makes it worse
it's really
strange like doing the other way around
because
i find myself at the 905 i'm like
so who answers what question who's my
boss and where do i go to and who are
you people you know you what's an
executive what's that but then like when
we're shooting like what i usually
always do it's like i have one point
person i know exactly who to go
you know
and it's it's it's
it's it's a very structure is very
strange for me yeah i feel that i i
don't think i would ever eat you guys
before i started on social media i got
fired from every single job really
all of them really where have you worked
before i worked at borders bookstore my
first job then i worked at yogurtland
then i worked at best buy what what did
they fire you for
your attitude
not my attitude so borders closed it was
a bookstore yeah and then yogurland fire
me
because i
i'm just not
good at doing things i don't want to do
yeah you know i'm really not and like
with my job like my jewelry company like
my youtube channel i am on it i'm good
at it
yeah like i have i have things working
one time i got fired for best buy from
best buy because my sister was also
working there and a customer got rowdy
with her and i was like you're not going
to talk to her like that so they fire me
so i mean it's just
yeah it was worth it but
life it's literally going gonna take you
where you're meant to be yeah there's i
could never see myself in a nine to five
not saying i can't do 905 work you know
i do it for my business but sitting
somewhere for that time
feels very restricting to me yeah but
there are people who love and want and
need that and those people are needed
yeah i also have a problem with the like
with authority like or when someone's
above me but like they're not like
better at their job or they're bad at
their job and then they're like
correcting me for i just can't handle it
and i feel like i would get fired for
not being able to
follow the rules or like follow what
they're telling me to do i think i found
a good middle ground because even though
it is nine to five it's something i'm
passionate about yeah yeah
yeah it's so funny right when you have
started like this spot into my head but
when you said borders i was like man she
was probably the best
restocker for the top shelf
what did she do
with dolls i didn't see what is
some people are the latter and if you
want to climb a tall glass of water
that's so sexy there you go something
like that
our next sponsor is dipsy
everyone needs an escape but those can
be hard to come by now uh answer dipsy
let yourself get lost in a world where
good things happen and we're your
pleasures is the only priority dipsy is
an audio app full of short sexy stories
designed to turn you on each dipsy audio
story features characters that feel like
real people and immersive scenarios so
you feel like you're right there listen
to stories about hooking up with your
hometown crush that you never made a
move on or that co-worker you've always
had a thing for or maybe a story that
puts you to bed with someone who's
telling you exactly what they'd like to
do to you oh my
okay okay
maybe this is no fingering it sounds
like porn for girls yeah it is porn for
girls
yeah if i ever like sexy stories if i
ever fail in my career i'm applying to
work here to read sexy stories because
that sounds fun that's a nine to five
you could get behind yeah right
they release new content every week so
there's always more to explore no matter
who you're into or what turns you on and
if you need to wind down dipsy also has
wellness sessions sensual bedtime
stories and soundscapes to help you
relax before you drift off dipsy's
starting to sound like a really good
boyfriend yeah wow he doesn't just want
to take care of you turn you on he wants
to take care of you that's really nice
for our listeners dipsy is offering an
extended 30-day free trial when you go
to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood again that's
dipsy stories dot com slash mood you got
a dirty mouth and you gotta clean it
but right before i go to bed with my
dirty stories of course i have to brush
my teeth and uh our next sponsor is
bruce an electric toothbrush that i've
been using lately it's really cool it's
an all-black matte uh matted black
toothbrush yeah it looks like it's from
the future the bristles are black too it
just looks really cool and the the the
base itself is like this crystal cut
looking thing and i've been i've been
using it a lot and tonight we're staying
over at nikki's spot so slumber party i
brought it with me bruce has six unique
modes to customize your brushing
experience it's a four week battery life
uh there's a magnetic charging stand
that's really cool and a really cute
compact travel case there's a
subscription program so you never forget
to change your brush head again because
you're supposed to change it out i've
seen some really disgusting brush heads
that are flattened out oh yeah thank you
flat out toothbrush i replaced steve's
uh toothbrush because of that and he
hadn't replaced it in like a year and he
got mad at me for throwing away his
toothbrush i'm like it's not even
cleaning your teeth bro
it's just the plastic part yeah it's
like completely
with the subscription program bruce
ships you a new replacement head every
six months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head steve
steve the design is also really slick
bruce's electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design it comes
in seasonal colors and looks great on
your bathroom counter it does you can
now get 15 off your brush toothbrush kit
and refill plan when you use a promo
code mood at bruce.com that's 50 off
using the promo code mood at b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com it's like brush but with two u's
once again from europe
bruce bruce bruce bruce
my teeth
once again go to bruce.com and use mood
for 15 off your bruce toothbrush kit and
a refill plan
this sounds russian brush brush okay
we got some time for a couple more i'm
trying to find a good one uh this one
made me kind of go hmm
[Music]
this person said their unpopular opinion
is that negative communication such as
yelling etc
is still better than zero communication
or just a lack of communication in your
relationship that really depends because
culturally sometimes it sounds like
people are yelling but they're just
communicating um like i was raised by a
greek lady and she used to always like
they used to always get in fights with
her daughter and they were like no we're
not fighting we're just communicating it
sounded like they were yelling at each
other but like verbal abuse is never
okay so
if someone's like actually yelling at
you and like
verbally abusing you like i don't know
what's best the silent treatment or it's
a toxic relationship either way so right
now yeah you probably shouldn't be in
that but toxic i mean the silent
treatment is really damaging yeah really
damaging oh i don't [ __ ] with that at
all like we're not we're not eight years
old if you're doing this silent
treatment i'm not i'm not dealing with
that so if you had to pick like one of
the two which one would you pick so i
would rather argue i'd rather be single
i would rather yell yeah i pick single
yeah yeah
yeah i mean you should be single it's
always an option i guess like yeah
yelling as long as it doesn't come down
to like
degrading or
calling or anything because i definitely
steve and i like
our tone gets louder like our volume
gets louder if we're in a heated
argument but it's never like we never
say things that are tearing the other
person down right it's just trying to
get your point across and like you're
just getting emotionally heated so it's
coming out louder yeah
kind of normal communication
as a human to talk and maybe sometimes
you raise your voice just to get your
point across as long as it's not damaged
yeah but if it's like [ __ ] you but it
sounds like she didn't know this person
is saying
negative communication is better than
none i don't know neither are good
that's like two opposite ends of a toxic
spectrum i think negative communication
i would man as opposed to silent
treatment maybe sometimes the silent
like not talking about it and just like
stepping away and silent and not
whatever is better than hearing [ __ ] you
you stupid [ __ ] but if anybody's
speaking to you that way please yeah
yeah or if you're speaking to anybody
that way you need therapy exactly and if
silent treatment is just like gathering
your thoughts then it's not necessarily
the science tactic yeah that's not the
silence you have to communicate i'm
going to take a couple
minutes i'm going to take an hour i'm
going to take you know a day to think
about this but what i mean by the silent
treatment is literally when they
stonewall you and they're completely
just like if you're sitting here talking
to me and i'm just like watching tv
that's yeah
toxic yeah yeah i don't agree with that
yeah you shouldn't be in either of those
no
those are both abuses i would say just
yeah entirely exit or seek therapy first
but if it doesn't get better entirely
exit i don't think something's better
than the other like why are we picking
up where are we picking toxic situations
to stay in if you're a girl cheating is
better than stealing yeah yeah but she's
just like just getting out i know you
stole money from my wallet but at least
you didn't cheat on me yeah right yeah
if you're still doing a silent treatment
as an adult you're a little [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you that right now i
don't care who you are i don't care if
you're [ __ ] seven feet tall with a
glock you're still a little [ __ ] that's
definitely
yes
dumb yeah i can't relate to anybody
doing this and if you and if you can't
argue without insulting someone you're
you're a little [ __ ] to grow up yeah
yeah i mean it's just uh we all have the
you know how we have love languages we
also have the way in which we fight yep
and if somebody is attacking who you are
as a person let's say if we're fighting
over the fact that this is here like
these bottles are here and i don't like
them but you do if i go to attack your
person i am then getting closer to the
end of the relationship right because
then i'm not
it's not the bottles that are bothering
me it's the lack of control i have over
you over the situation you don't like
those bottles where are you [ __ ]
idiot yeah
that's abusive
oh my god i hope if anybody's getting
spoken to that what you realize that you
shouldn't be ever getting spoken to that
way because you can fight you can argue
but i have never called my boyfriend out
of his name he has never called me out
of his name yeah we get loud because
you're passionate about the topic and
even then he'll be like we need to take
some time off because you're screaming
and i'm like oh
yeah you know
yeah because you're like you're right
and i hate it yeah
but
there's never a lack of disrespect going
at the person yes there's actually um
gottman the institute of gottman yeah
study that have you guys talked about
this no we talked about it on other
pockets oh okay so they can predict the
goblins their couple of therapists are
married and they said they can predict
by looking at a couple mm-hmm if they
will be divorced depending on the way in
which they argue 90 accurate yeah so
they hire
the force horsemen of the apocalypse so
these four things will determine if your
relationship will survive one of them is
stonewalling so the silent treatment
the other one is when you are in fights
when you're attacking the person instead
of the issue so instead of me saying i
really don't like the fact that you'll
give your socks there it's like you
freaking disgusting pig why do you
always leave your socks there yeah uh
what are the other two do you guys know
them yeah um wasn't there the kitchen
sink one i i learned this in my brief
time in college
like i took a class that was
interpersonal relationships and we went
over these but i feel like one was like
it's called kitchen sinking where you
just throw all of your past
like resentments of this person and you
just start throwing you just throw and
all like and that one time when you
cheated on me and then you like lied
during this time and then yeah that's
that was one of those like if you keep
bringing all the issues up yeah yeah you
guys should definitely look it up
especially if you're in a relationship
because i always keep it very present in
my mind you know they also did this
study where they um oh yeah
so criticism so if it's if i critique
who you are contempt is they call this
when you're just like let's say jess
keeps doing something that keeps
bothering me and instead of
talking about it i'm like well it's just
the way she is she's never going to
change
you know you're just content with it
you're just like the uh the rolling of
the eyes
it's morals
oh what is it attacking sense of self
with an intention to insult or
psychologically so that's the socks the
dirty socks
defensiveness is seeing yourself as a
victim
yeah
oh yeah yeah so the other one
defensiveness is let's say if you keep
telling me oh my god like you're always
leaving your stuff everywhere and i'm
like well you always do this
it's always my fault why do you always
have to point it at me you know instead
of saying [ __ ] yeah instead of saying
you know what i am sorry that i keep
leaving my stuff everywhere like i'll
start being more tidy around the house
so yeah those yeah that's a really good
article
i forget what they called it but it was
like thin sampling or something where
they basically they took like thin
slices of
people's arguments and just from the
compilation of like thin sound bites
that they had they were able to predict
what the couple would make it or not
that's wild
yeah let me throw in one last um one
it's a it's definitely a strong one
okay unpopular opinion
our triggers are our responsibility for
example you can't attack someone for
sharing their own trauma online because
it triggers you everyone has a right to
deal with trauma in their own way unless
it involves attacking someone obviously
the internet is triggering and we all
know when we decide to get online so to
say if a video is triggering you feel
upset enough to attack the creator you
probably shouldn't be on the internet i
should seek counseling yes i feel like
because i see this a lot on tick tock
all the time i feel like if someone were
to add a trigger it doesn't like a
trigger warning doesn't hurt that's
awesome for doing that but if someone
doesn't do it you you can't just attack
them be like how dare you like you
should really put a trigger warning blah
blah blah it's like i'm not responsible
for you the world doesn't come with
trigger warnings i remember i posted
something like we did a skit where like
i was like a drunk mother and somebody
posted you should really put a trigger
warning for that because there's some of
us who grew up with drunk parents and it
triggers us i'm like and a part of me is
like i i kind of want to empathize with
you but another part of me just like
shut the [ __ ] up the world doesn't work
that way it happened a lot with comedy
because the way that i would write
sketches and like do stand-up is i'm
running from things that triggered me
that traumatized me that like i'm
getting out in in comedy form it's like
i'm taking something dark and turning it
light and making fun of responsibility
for it yeah and then but then people
would be like why are you making light
of this issue you know i cause i did one
sketch on depression and people were
like you're like adding to the stigma by
making light of depression like no no i
have depression and it's terrible and
i'm making light of it because it makes
me feel better that's how i deal with it
yeah it's like that's my coping
mechanism for it you choose your own
maybe yours is therapy but
yeah yeah i really really it's hard
really dislike that whole like yelling
at people for not putting a trigger
warning yeah because now it's like okay
i see there are legitimate things you
know that can trigger people i
understand that but i have been noticing
people complaining about even just like
the smaller things yeah they're
triggering
um like i said the the drunken acting
one there was one um
you really should put a trigger warning
for mouth noises um
i think first of all [ __ ]
person has to be joking no like these
people are dead serious you know and
it's just why do you guys think that is
can they never watch movies because what
if something happens in there then i
think it's because there's a
victimization like kind of like i want
to i want to feel like you get there's
some people you just love that feeling
you know like baby me i'm i'm different
because i'm special because i went
through that trauma and now you're
bringing it out yeah exactly yeah they
want to feel that yeah so then how do
you define what should have a trigger
warning and what shouldn't because for
example if you're going to talk about
like i watch a lot of true crime and
they always say warning we're gonna be
talking about these crimes this happened
if this is triggering to you please exit
right so to that i'm like okay cool so
then who are we to decide and who
decides what deserves a trigger warning
and what doesn't i have an answer
i think if you're talking about a
serious topic like let's say i'm going
to talk about suicide and then i give a
suicide trigger warning and i'm going to
talk like detailed about
it steps leading up to it yeah it's
gonna get a huge picture exactly and
it's very visceral yeah if you're
tuning in to watch a comedy sketch like
it's comedy yeah
[ __ ] you you don't get trigger warning
exactly sorry you didn't click on this
thinking it was going to be a serious
discussion topic it's just something
that like people are making fun of or
bringing light to or you know trying to
make people laugh from a source of pain
which is what comedy is in all sitcoms
the person you're laughing at is going
through pain like the main character is
usually it's painful for them it's funny
for us yeah and that's what comedy is
and so if you're gonna click on it it's
usually a lot lighter too like it just
kind of yeah it's a little brush of like
this happened or whatever it's not just
to set up this whole picture exactly
you know what's kind of interesting so
the other day i posted a tick tock and
it's kind of like damned if you're doing
them if you don't because
can i i don't know if i could say the r
word like what happens to girls i could
say it here on the podcast if you just
want to say our word just okay
yeah you know what that means okay so i
was talking about that because this girl
it happened to her so i wanted to share
it and like talk about it and so i said
the r word i was like oh she was our
word and these people instead of saying
what they are and then this girl said
why don't you just say
and then she said the word she's like
um saying the r word and uh what is it
called when you
censor yeah and censoring it she's like
saying that saying the r word and
censoring it takes its power away and
somebody else commented and was like you
know i'm glad she's doing that because
i'm a victim and this is triggering and
it's a serious topic so it kind of left
me a little bit confused because i was
like what do we do like do we actually
say it and put it all out there or are
do we are we mindful of the fact that
people have been through it you know
that's an interesting that's a fine line
i think i don't i don't even have an
opinion or answer for that right it's
hard and the reason why i censored it
because i would say it but i know that
tick tock would take down
things that are talking about that just
like youtube would flag you guys if we
set it here so
i think it's one of those things where
you can't make everybody happy yeah and
it's one of those things that as
creators we just have to be like well i
did my best yeah
sorry yeah yeah it really is oh i know
exhausted there's there's
it's definitely hard because there are
some things that deserve a trigger
warning yeah absolutely i think the more
extreme stuff yeah they're really really
extreme yeah the more in-depth exactly i
think these people would say who are you
to say what's extreme for me and what's
not yeah it's hard to decide yeah
obviously how are you going to make it
through life if like the non-extreme
things are going to be triggered like
you're just not going to be able to
watch any movie any tv show any anything
i mean for me and i don't know why this
is but like i can't watch violence like
at all like i can't watch the news i
can't watch like even boxing matches i i
don't like when people are getting
physically hurt yeah and so even in
movies when someone gets stabbed or like
they're fighting i have to like cover my
eyes but i don't expect the world to not
yeah like if we're gonna watch a movie
like and i'm sensitive about that i'm
just gonna go like this during it or i
won't click on news videos i won't click
on things that i know are gonna trigger
me like you can censor your timeline
yeah this like a video or block the
person who's yes yeah i mean i
definitely think we're a different
generation and i know that the gen c
generation has said how we say that
they're babies and stuff but
i think it's just everyone's different
and it's a different way in which we
have grown up and we're just all trying
our best yeah it really comes down to
listen if
you have those triggers you're
responsible for it you can't go into
someone else's space and tell them what
to do yeah you can't be like oh i don't
like violence and you go on a page
called i kill people.com and you just
yell at them like how dare you go to a
boxing match and yeah like end the
violence exactly like you're putting
yourself in that situation and you have
no one to blame but yourself yeah
i have a we're going to need to wrap up
pretty soon uh because we've almost
reached our hour but i did have a final
one that i kind of wanted to interject
because i think it's it's like kind of
following
um i had a discussion with someone who
follows me um earlier and i posted a
meme
that said something about what is um
look down upon when you're poor but is
cool when you're rich and it's that meme
i think everyone's kind of probably seen
it by now it's like when you're poor
um like not paying your taxes doing
drugs like all like it lists like all
these things
speaking two languages like all that
stuff is like gross when you're poor but
cool when you're rich and then so i
added to it i said well i think doing
drugs is also trashy when you're rich
like i don't think that being rich or
poor drug use is cool in any way but
then this person messaged me and was
like well i think you should take into
consideration the shame that someone
might feel if they're a drug user blah
blah and all this stuff and i was like
so my unpopular opinion is i'm not that
worried about other people's shame yeah
like and i also think that shame uh
plays a role in society and making
people do better yeah so like in certain
circumstances we use shame as a way to
make things better as in like the metoo
movement like we've used shame to shame
men from that shitty [ __ ] behavior
that they were doing in all of the
workplaces so now they're all kind of
like
leaving us the [ __ ] alone now
sometimes the online shaming [ __ ] when
people are bulling up bullying up and
gathering on people and dog piling you
know just all that stuff like i can see
places where that's not good not
everyone deserves to be piled on with
shame but like also if i make a meme and
you feel ashamed because you're a drug
addict and i hit something in you i
personally
don't really feel responsible for your
shame like not no yeah
we're not responsible for anybody's
feelings yeah but they like to hold
creators accountable yeah because they
don't want to hold themselves
accountable for their own feelings yeah
or work through their own issues yeah
like are you mad because i said it or
are you mad because you see yourself in
it yeah yeah
yeah i mean i i feel ashamed when
certain things hit me too but like i
just have to deal with it like oh yeah
that's actually true about me wow i feel
ashamed and you know what i'm going to
try to do better now yeah instead of
like oh take that down it's like
no wait i needed that mirror put up to
my face like consider that too like why
do we have to take down every single
thing that might offend you because
you're ashamed of your own behavior yeah
we don't necessarily have to do that put
more effort into
bettering yourself than getting angry
yeah but that doesn't go for victims of
yeah of course obviously this is just
like
sometimes your own behavior it's like i
don't need to censor myself because your
behavior is bad yeah i feel like any
time i've gotten angry at something it's
a it's a moment where you can use that
for self-reflection and like understand
why you're getting angry at something i
used to do this exercise like when i was
writing stand-up a lot i would actually
go through the day and if i got angry at
something i'd write it down so that i
can make jokes about it because
anger
sadness any extreme emotions that
something's making you feel you should
examine that and like understand why it
works and so i would come up with
reasons of why i was feeling that way
and some of them would be funny and that
it would lead to like a stand-up bit but
um but for just for healing's sake like
to get through that like understanding
yourself is so important it really is
otherwise you're just gonna go through
life being triggered at everything and
not knowing why and that's even more
unbearable i think that at least
understanding why and it's hard to talk
about this because the right wing and
political spectrum has taken over being
like oh trigger snowflakes like i don't
agree with that [ __ ] either that [ __ ]
bothers me when they're like oh you're
such a snowflake yeah i'm like shut the
[ __ ] up there's room for display
you can have empathy yeah and then also
i don't want it to like people to put us
in that box like but there is a middle
ground we have empathy for you just
don't you should
that's just the thing you just don't
push it well here's another trigger
warning we're ending the podcast yeah oh
my god oh hang on so i
on like what stacy and i agreed on that
no one else did
what why don't you just tell us because
it's a whole discussion
tune in next month when stacy is our
guest all day i know they're gonna
forget
if you're in a relationship you don't
have to be friends with the opposite sex
oh no no no no my opinion was
it's impossible to be friends with the
opposition oh i remember this yeah yeah
and i still stand on that i will die and
we will talk about it next month make
sure you guys like the video give us
five stars thumbs up or whatever stars
and we'll see make sure you give me all
the compliments on my eyelashes and
stacy all the compliments on her heights
leave your unpopular opinion in the
comments too because i want to fight and
go check out stacey's instagram on her
her youtube channel go to her jewelry
and what was this support the podcast
how go by going to our spot go to our
sponsors even if you even if you just go
check out the website even if you don't
buy it's great just like let them know
we sent some traffic over there like hey
maybe i'm considering a purple mattress
i'm going to go check out that yeah i'm
going to maybe use that code all the
links to everyone and everything will be
able to or comment on their instagram be
like hey we saw you know you and the
baby yeah
anyways thanks guys for watching love
you bye